this is a white pill moment for
everybody this is Hope and optimism
Target makes emergency calls after
backlash to quote tuck friendly bathing
suits and other Pride products the
company is terrified of a Bud Light
situation a Target Insider told Fox News
the company's lgbtq themed items were
released this month and include tuck
friendly bathing suits chest binders and
packing underwear along with gender
fluid mugs and and other things and I'm
pretty sure this was like for children
is what the big issue was
consumers called for a boycott of Target
over the products taking issue with the
swimwear as well as Pride themed
children's clothing including onesies
t-shirt socks and swim skirts with a tag
rating thoughtfully fit on multiple body
types and gender Expressions Target also
says a collection of children's books
focused on lgbtq issues Target is evil
if a company targets kids that company
shouldn't exist Bud Light them to the
conservative media personality
personality Liz wheeler
Matt Walsh of course was saying this is
worse than anything Bud Light has done
of course and so the reporting
apparently is that we have this from the
post-millennial
Target to move Pride merch to the back
of stores to avoid Bud Light situation
quote we were given 36 hours until they
take all of our pride stuff the entire
section and move it into a section
that's a third of the size
that's amazing Bud Light is seeing
another major drop in sales they're
nearly 30 percent down year over year
you'd love to see it it's getting worse
and worse for them conservatives simply
said we have no brand loyalty to Bud
Light this is the scariest thing in the
world for the biggest brands there's no
brand loyalty to Target nobody's walking
around wearing Target charts being like
yeah go Target Bud Light at least had
some brand recognition with sports and
that didn't do anything for them so when
it comes to your choice between Target
and Walmart if people are going to be
like Target's bad we won't go there it's
not a big deal to shop somewhere else I
really hope that conservative stick to
this because a few years ago we saw a
similar attempt to boycott Target when
they were saying we're going to allow
men to use the women's room and abdicate
our responsibility to protect female
patrons in our stores and conservative
said I'm never shopping at Target again
and then many of them started shopping
at Target again so I hope that this is
truly a bridge too far and that people
are going to stick to it this time I
would also say that if this isn't stuck
to it's going to set a very bad
precedent right because people are
seeing this as the sort of sequel to the
Bud Light boycott and if it falls apart
here that's going to say a lot about the
power of conservatives as
protesters or as boycotters of products
honestly I don't think you really need
to identify as conservative to have
issues with child sex changes I'm not
that conservative really in life but
little kids that are getting their
parents are like cutting their body
parts off and stuff like that just as a
human I I kind of wonder what in the
hell is going on Tim's cracking a beer
what was that Ian I didn't I couldn't
hear what you were saying as I was
pulling out this wonderful stud light
lager if anybody would like a lion hey
stud light feel free to grab a cannon
this is uh no joke I don't know if you
can see it uh stud light stud light and
there's a there's a cowboy on it with a
horse uh and it's from Harvest Gap
Brewery in Hillsboro uh Virginia that's
hilarious so we just we were just
driving past this Brewery and we walked
in and I noticed they had something
called stud light
that's really good I'm uh I'm not a big
Beer Drinker but I had no choice but to
buy a beer called stud light with a
manly cowboy on it because I have to
wonder I'm not saying the brewery did
anything to uh what you want to just
grab one yeah here here you go yeah plus
we got a bunch down there surgery yeah
whatever you don't take it I'm not I'm
not saying that I don't know if this
Brewery made this intentionally because
of what was happening but to see that
they've got stud light and there's a
cowboy on it I was like I kind of feel
like you know they're they're having fun
super fun and it's a light lager and
it's pretty good yeah but anyway I just
I just thought it'd be funny if we just
cracked something if you look if you
look at Bud light's Market though I mean
you know you know what Ian was talking
about just to be offended by targeting
kids for this is a whole different
cross-section than just conservatives
but if you look at who shops at Target
it's not as much like who buys your
stuff at Target I mean a little bit of
everybody but who drinks Bud Light I
mean mean yeah the people that used to
drink Bud Light uh aren't going to go
along with this whole trans movement
kind of Dylan Mulvaney kind of thing and
they're also not going to buy it was an
April Fool's joke and so Bud Light made
a bad situation worse by not owning it
yeah and and now okay their ESG score
took a tally instead of owning that
they're still trying to to oh but see
but we can do everything and it's like
no man this is a tea intersection you're
gonna have to pick you can either keep
the people that used to drink Bud Light
or you can go woke
um
I think the thing with the Bud Light and
Target is that
target has it is smart of them to panic
in the way they're panicking yeah and
they should probably just remove these
products because the left will try and
lie but um look
I don't care what an adult wants to do
you know uh you know Sheamus and I will
have a disagreement on this like I don't
care about someone who's lgbtq or
whatever privacy of your own home these
are all the old traditional arguments
from liberals you live your life you'll
be happy you we mind our own business
keep the kids out of it
they're now trying to argue that the
lgbtq stuff is not inherently sexual
it's quite literally what it is
LGBT quite literally are references to
sexual identities and sexualities
there's no reason for you to bring that
to children
this is what Target is doing they should
not be doing that here's what I think
Bud Light loses about 25 of its its its
Market with this whole stunt and they're
not going to get it back they they may
still see growth because new people
under the market and population is well
if the population expands if it doesn't
then they're going to lose more more
drinkers
but I don't think it'll go to zero right
they've seen about a 30 drop off so far
it's like 28 or something like that
these are the people who pay attention
who don't want to drink Bud Light don't
want to be seen drinking Bud Light so a
lot of people don't care they don't
watch the news they don't they're not on
Twitter they're not on the internet they
just went to the they went to the liquor
store to get some beer and they said Bud
light's half off and they went wow me
and my buddies want to get drunk we'll
take it half off some people might even
know and just be like don't know don't
care cheap beer with Target I think
you'll see something similar a lot of
people who know will just say I will not
shop there anymore that's why Target is
freaking out not because they're gonna
go out of business but because they
could lose 30 percent of their customers
in a month and that's bad news I agree
with basically everything you're saying
there's just one thing I'd probably
phrase differently and I think you'd
actually agree with me on this when you
said there's no reason for them to be
introducing the sexual stuff to children
we know there's a reason we know what
the reason is it's because they want to
groom these kids
yeah Target I think the people at Target
who are trying to normalize this yeah
there's there's an entire effort within
our systems to push sexually perverse
behaviors onto children it's they're
owned by Vanguard BlackRock State Street
these companies keep popping up any uh
anything any of these publicly traded
things I mean those three corporations
BlackRock Vanguard and State Street own
like 24 of Target they are pushing an
agenda I completely agree with you
Sheamus and it is it is bad look um you
know my kids are at a point where I
never thought gee we need to cover boys
are different than girls and all that
stuff it's you know pretty pretty
intuitive but we're at an age where you
know they're very overtly introducing
this to kids and people say well you
know Ginger's a spectrum and it's
totally different than sex uh no you're
given cross-sex hormones you're using
cross-sex pronouns and the surgeries
that you want to do including to minors
are on the sexually distinctive physical
attributes of your Anatomy you cannot
change you're either an XY person male
or an XX person you can't change your
bone structure everything else you can't
change those attributes with rare
exception yeah like points it's out
there there are some uh there's some
there's some variants but that's not
what we're having this debate about
right you know those sections at Target
and you know the whole transgenderism
movement that's going on in the country
of spreading all over the place isn't
the traditional you know cross
uh you know issue with hormones that
come their DNA chromosome uh issues that
you're talking about so look at XY
people they're different than XX people
uh everyone has gotten that for all of
time until very recently
yeah no absolutely you mentioned this
point about us having to debate the
differences between boys and girls and
you not thinking you to be at this point
I feel similarly I first became
interested in politics when I was about
eight years old because I I learned what
abortion was and it was so shocking to
me that anyone could consider that a
morally acceptable thing or that it
would be legal and so I've been
interested in these things from a very
early age and I had some hope as a kid
that by the time I was an adult if I
ever had any kind of political career or
a career in commentary we would have
moved on to other issues and Society
might have progressed of course my
optimism was misplaced here we are 20
years later and we're we're debating the
differences between boys and girls
literally well I don't we've completely
regressed I don't think we're debating
them I think there is a cult that will
lie cheat and steal so they'll come to
you and pretend like there's a debate to
trick you into debating them because
they know that you'll operate in good
faith debate those ideas interesting
meanwhile I mean look I know I think
there's truth in that it's the video of
Jack besoba getting punched by the
leftist and then when the cops pull up
because the cops watch it happen the
leftists one of them goes I didn't see
anything happen they're just lying about
everything they know the difference
between boys and girls they're just
trying to destroy the system it seems
like yeah when you when you disrupt the
system it's the person that's the most
powerful that suffers the most so like
if you cut everybody's value by five
percent it's the rich it's the one with
the most value that's going to lose the
most because five percent of the most is
more than five percent of less than that
so like covid shut down the entire world
the United States it's probably suffered
the most because it was doing the best
uh and now we've got the disruption of
the Youth of the psychology of the youth
the United States has the most to lose
because it's the leader of the planet
and I don't think it's I don't think
it's an accident man it's a global
internet when you cut off the Tall Grass
the Short Grass stays where it is I I'm
gonna I'm gonna slightly push back
against both things I hear what you're
saying and I think I I agree overall but
when it comes to who can suffer the most
so for example you're right that someone
who's extremely wealthy and loses five
percent of their wealth has lost more
material wealth technically speaking but
if a poor person is living paycheck to
paycheck and then they lose five percent
of their wealth maybe they can't afford
to pay rent anymore and similarly we saw
during covid the the UN
increased the number of people projected
to be at risk for starvation in the
third world by like 130 million so there
are certain things that Western
countries can tolerate that poorer
countries can't and that's actually part
of why you see it here right because we
are so wealthy that we've been able to
insulate ourselves from natural
consequences for decades if you had a
poorer Society the sexual Revolution
would have fallen apart almost
immediately because what happens when a
man starts impregnating women and then
he doesn't care for those children right
I mean it's it's social and economic
pandemonium and very wealthy Nations can
insulate themselves from that for a
little while leftism only exists in in
wealthy Nations that's right that's
exactly it the woke mind virus is Elon
Musk kind of tagged it is really only in
affluent countries there's no like big
woke mind virus spreading all over
Africa they're not transgender outbreaks
all over the global South it's in
affluent countries it's it's you know I
talked about this too a while ago when I
said feminism can only exist in in a in
an uh Empire's sphere the United States
is so secure that we no longer fear for
our women
if you go back to to uh tribal era
medieval whatever when you're really
worried about wild animals and disease
you stub your toe you die the men are
very desperately like if the women die
we are wiped out as a civilization so
the women are protected we can keep them
in homes keep them in the camps around
them
you get to the point where you have a
very strong military a very expansive
country crime gets goes way down and we
start exuding military force out of the
country and so we Face very little
threats from within then all of a sudden
there's nothing to worry about with
women reaching higher positions in
government I know this one probably
triggers the feminist but this is why
you don't see these things like you
mentioned in other parts of the world
where they are less affluent less safe
less secure very true if if we lived in
a violent Society where people got
attacked and and shot at and stabbed and
raped outside just walking down the
street it would be risky to send your
wife out to the grocery store it
wouldn't happen as much the guy would be
the one that did that it still is it
still is a Trope of don't walk down a
dark alley and the feminists have been
trying there's this weird inflection
point where crime was down enough to
where the left started saying stop
victim blaming but for the longest time
we would tell people don't go walk
through a dark alley at night and women
should be should be worried despite the
fact that men are more likely to be
victims of violent crime it's also true
that men are more likely to physic to be
able to physically defend themselves
from another man and but it's but it's
not just about men I'm talking about
wild animals and just general danger if
you go way back to humans and try in the
tribal in a tribal era if 90 if you have
a tribe if you have 100 men and 100
women and 99 women die that tribe ceases
to exist if 99 men die they'll struggle
but they'll probably be okay well it's
not even just a calculation right it's
men caring about the women in their
lives and recognizing because they're
not insulated from the consequences of
their actions by an unfathomable amount
of wealth that men and women do have to
be in different roles in order to be
maximally safe and so this is something
that you have to be unbelievably wealthy
to even start to consider as a society
the idea that you would start to swap
roles between men and women when you're
living in a state of nature right when
you're one bad Harvest away from your
entire family style starving you're not
like preoccupied with whether you were
called bossy when a man would have been
called assertive it's not even a
question and it's not to say that a
society where people are worried about
starving all the time is better however
I will say there's no argument to be
made that those people aren't stronger
and more virtuous than we are today and
I'll also add that we could have the
best of both worlds if people were
capable of living with wealth while
still having a spirit of poverty there's
no generational memory that's the
problem we we cannot we we don't know
what it's like to to you know be
preparing for Harvest some people do but
you know the United States and to say
we've only three months of food prepared
for the winter yeah we're in trouble
we're going to have to eat less and Hunt
more if we're gonna make it through this
one yeah and I mean if you look on
balance I mean one of my favorite sites
out there is like human progress.org
work everyone's like oh you know we got
too many people we're never going to
make it you know the malthusians were
saying that forever they were wrong on
balance human progress is great the
innovation has given us lots of
flexibility but the question is how do
we keep the the ties that bind us I mean
you know part of our motto is this idea
of e pluribus unum and and part of the
way that you teach that is values and
culture shared values and you think
about how easy it was you go back to you
know what you guys are talking about the
state of nature if everyone could live
by just a basic truth of don't hurt
people and don't take their stuff uh we
would really not even need government
right everything would work just fine
and because people can't abide by that
simple Maxim well somebody's got to be
the judge of well who was wrong to hurt
whoever here and look at how much
government we have now versus how little
we could have If people could simply not
hurt one another or take their stuff we
have a constitution that's supposed to
have a limited form of government but
now we have far more government than
will fit within our Constitution and I I
think the challenge today is how do we
get a government small enough to fit
back in the Constitution because we can
afford a government that small I think
uh I think just conflict will emerge
conflict will emerge I think that uh
we we look at things that are um
we look at hard times as bad things but
I don't think they are I think there
needs to be a balance between the good
times and the bad times to create strong
well-balanced individuals who are
capable of surviving hard times and I
feel like you know there's a saying uh
Good Times make weak men week men you
know hard times Etc
but I also feel like it's kind of
swinging back and forth like a pendulum
increasing the amount of energy each
time
you get a good time then you get weak
men which give you a hard time and then
it keeps swinging back and forth in
terms of the the
of how extreme it gets what I'm trying
to say is right now we are dealing with
a very serious crisis in the United
States and in other parts of the world
with actual War
we have many many weak men in fact I
think this country is the overwhelming
majority of men in this country are are
weak for example in New York Daniel
Penny defends people on a train
did anybody in New York come out with
signs to protest for Daniel Penny maybe
a couple here and there but was there
like a big March where the police were
yelling at them and they're blocking
cars saying he's a hero no we don't see
that we do however see a lot of people
putting up a lot of money which for a
lot of people can be even more
courageous if you're seriously if you're
saying like I'm going to take a portion
of my resources and allocated defense
defending this man so my point is not
that there are no strong men or strong
people but then in places like New York
and these big cities you are more likely
to see people say
I better keep my head down and not
engage and I was saying this to Glenn
Beck earlier
I don't think the problem is that evil
exists I think the problem is that good
men do nothing yeah it's a great quote
for a reason and you go back to the
Declaration of Independence you know
they pledged their lives their Fortunes
in their sacred honor because that's
what it takes to defend a country and
that's look we're only the the land of
the free if we are in fact the home of
the brave and it does take courage
whether it's to cut a check to show up
to an event to participate you got to
make the current system work or it is
going to fail strength also is kind of
uh like Darwin would say it's not the
strongest of the species that survives
but the most adaptable to change it's
the most adaptable humans that get by
which I think is why people aren't
stepping up sometimes is because they
want to just get by they want to fit in
to survive but you know sometimes you
need people to break the mold I wanna I
wanna jump down yeah I want to piggyback
on that because I think that's a very
very good point were you finished though
I'm not sure okay so I think that's a
very good point and one thing I would
argue is that
virtue is what makes you adaptable right
a person who's living a life of Vice is
taking the path of least resistance and
what they're doing is engaging in
behaviors that feel good for them in the
moment rather than behaving rationally
making a long-term plan and behaving
based on what's going to be good for
them down the line when you're able to
do that when you're able to use your
rational faculties to like subordinate
your passions to what's going to be good
for you in the long run you can adapt to
many different kinds of situations but
if you've made yourself accustomed
simply to or accustomed simply to doing
whatever feels good for you well once
the dynamic changes you're gonna have
absolutely no idea how to interact with
the world thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time